avec nous mais l'année jolie ministre du
patrimoine canadien responsable est
langue officielle madame joly bonsoir
vous venez de voir le reportage vous
étiez vous à demain donc la procession
des ministres commun on va parler de
votre ministère mais d'abord je veux
savoir comment vous avez vécu vous cette
cérémonie fait une très belle cérémonie
en faire beaucoup d'excitation lorsque
les ministes on s'est réunis dans
l'autobus
on n'avait pas tous consciente qui avait
quoi comme responsabilités donc et
qu'ils allaient former le cabinet alors
ça a été beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
surprises
beaucoup de belles conversations très
beaux moments et par la suite en fait de
vivre cet événement là avec nos proches
mais également avec un beau bain de
foule plusieurs personnes qui faisaient
partie de en fait de l'événement c'était
vraiment touchant parce que vous savez
autant campagne électorale on a voulu
faire en sorte
monsieur trudeau et l'équipe nous avons
voulu par en sorte de passer un message
de véritables changements d'optimisme et
la main c'était aussi un message
d'humilité un message je l'espère
d'authenticité aussi que la terre nous
sommes tous des députés nous
représentants nous représentes ton la
population et 20 nous voulons faire en
sorte de redonner confiance par rapport
à la politique et aux services publics
en particulier entre à parité diversité
ça m'est apparu comme une évidence comme
c'était très très clairs justin trudeau
a parlé après la conférence de presse en
disant c'est le canada de 2015 alors on
vous a donné le patrimoine canadien
comment vous voyez votre nouveau défi
comment vous voyez ce ministère la puis
donnez moi la priorité que j'aurai dans
les dix prochains jours par exemple
mais vous savez le ministère du
patrimoine canadien et des langues
officielles
après neuf ans de gouvernement
conservateur ces militaires des symboles
c'est le ministère en fait de du
progressiste de présenter exactement une
nouvelle vision
de retisser des liens avec la communauté
les différentes communautés
particulièrement les artisans à travers
le pays nos artistes
c'est également un ministère qui fait
face à énormément défi d'un point de vue
numérique et pour faire en sorte que
nous ayons un radiodiffuseur public de
2015 un radiodiffuseur public moderne et
donc d'appuyer le virage numérique de
sibiti radio canada va être certainement
partie de mes priorités
même si en même temps c'est ce que j'ai
l'air qui comprend le 150e anniversaire
de la confédération qui va avoir lieu
sous peu en fait en 2010 est en même
temps que le 375e anniversaire de
montréal
donc ça va être très très important de
pouvoir célébrer ce grand événement là
partout à travers le canada et mais vous
avez au québec la dernière fois qu'on a
vécu un tel événement mais c'était lors
de l'expo 67
alors c'est vraiment un plaisir de
pouvoir avoir cette responsabilité là
pour créer justement un grand symbole
canadien en 2007 vous avez parlé du
radiotélédiffuseurs public donc de radio
canada cbc radio canada est ce que les
gens placent actuellement vous souhaitez
l'échangé est ce que vous avez confiance
au leadership actuel comment vous voyez
les choses au cours des prochains jours
bien entendu je vais avoir l'occasion de
avoir mi séance de breffage rencontré à
mon équipe
les rencontrer toute l'équipe de
patrimoine canadien de radio canada et
entend et lyon pour prendre les
décisions qui sont importantes
on sait déjà que lors de la campagne
électorale on a présenté un
investissement massif dans radio canada
150 millions $ de plus donc donc sur ses
engagements pendant la campagne
c'était un engagement monsieur triaud
l'a clairement dit de faire en sorte
justement de respecter nos promesses qui
ont été présentés en campagne électorale
et non seulement ses 150 millions de
plus dans radio canada alors qu'il y
avait déjà eu des coupes de 115 millions
donc c'est plus que les coupes de
monsieur harper mais c'est aussi
investir doubler le budget du conseil
des arts investir dans
donc ça tient dans votre esprit déjà les
vous battre et au canada vous allez vous
battre pour le contient des heures par
exemple de rétablir à 360 millions je
crois et le conseil des arts donc il
fait vivre pas mal d'artistes au pays
ça c'est des engagements que vous allez
vous aller batailler pour les respecter
en tout cas passer un peu tirés entre
les ministères la wii mais vous pouvez
être sûr que je vais une fois forte au
conseil des ministres pour s'assurer
justement qu'on a un respect de notre
patrimoine canadien qu'on a un respect
de nos artisans on a un respect de notre
radio diffuseur public
je parlais tantôt en point de presse
avec mon collègue scott griffin qui lui
est au conseil du trésor et que ça lui
porte en lui ce avec lui pour choyer à
mais c'est avec lui qu'on parlait de
l'importance de redonner confiance à nos
à nos fonctionnaires anneaux aux
personnes qui travaillent au sein du
gouvernement fédéral
mais c'est la même chose en fait pour
radio-canada revalorisé en fait le
travail des artisans pas au canada et
emilie 63 minutes sur l'île de montréal
premier minis sur l'île de montréal
évidemment qu'est ce que ça vous dit sur
la place de montréal pour les prochaines
années mais que montréal redevient
important dans l'agenda tahoua clos
québec lors du 9 octobre dernier a
décidé d'élire 40 députés une grande
réputation au sein d'un gouvernement
libéral et que montréal et le québec
redevient important en fait à l'agenda à
tahoua et puis je suis honoré d'avoir
reçu la confiance des citoyens dans ces
quartiers villes à montréal pour bien
les représenter
mais au-delà de ça aussi de faire partie
de l'équipe qui va pouvoir justement à
bien défendre les intérêts de notre
métropole et vous allez bien vous
entendre avec le maire connaît mais ça
ça va de soi mélanie joly félicitations
pour votre nomination merci à la
prochaine c1